okay we have to get into now the
potential potential unconstitutionality
lack of constitutionality of Donald
Trump's installation of a replacement to
Attorney General Jeff Sessions who he
forced to resign last week specifically
of Matt Whittaker jeff Sessions chief of
staff there is this thing we have in the
United States called the Constitution
Article 2 section 2 Clause 2 says that
principal officers of the United States
must be nominated by the President and
confirmed by the Senate under its advice
and consent powers Matthew Whitaker who
has been installed by Trump to replace
Jeff Sessions was not confirmed by the
Senate and there is growing legal
opinion from progressive liberal leftist
legal scholars and from conservative
legal scholars that this appointment is
simply not constitutional there is
Supreme Court precedent here there's
actually a case from last year on which
even trumps favor Justice Clarence
Thomas agreed that the general counsel
of the National Labor Relations Board
had been invalid on statutory grounds
but Clarence Thomas wrote in his opinion
that even if the statute had allowed the
appointment of this General Counsel to
the NLRB the Constitution's appointments
clause would not have allowed it that
was for the general counsel to the
National Labor Relations Board we're
talking about the Attorney General right
now and there's a legal opinion that was
published in the New York Times by two
co-authors
one is George Conway the third who is
Trump advisor Kellyanne Conway's husband
this is a right-winger okay who says the
installation of Matthew Whitaker is not
constitutional now what are the counter
arguments from the right for those who
say it's fine to put in Matthew Whitaker
well one of the arguments that they're
making is that if sessions had been
fired it would be true that it would not
be allowed to install Matthew Whitaker
on this basis but that because jeff
sessions resigned of course he was
forced to resign
we typically call that a firing he is
therefore Matthew Whitaker is therefore
not an appointment but it's someone
being put in as acting a journey
Attorney General until someone is
actually appointed and confirmed but but
but the argument here is a
constitutional one that consent that
advice and consent are required and that
it applies to this situation period that
it doesn't matter whether Jeff Sessions
resigned or was fired but they will say
what about Sally Yates Sally Yates was
acting Attorney General for so long
David don't you remember that well I
don't remember it because she was acting
Attorney General for ten days this is a
lie that is being spread everywhere
Sally Yates was only acting Attorney
General from January I forget the dates
it was late January of 2017 it was about
a 10-day period but there is a really
important difference here Pat between
Sally Yates and Matt Whittaker Sally
Yates had been confirmed by the Senate
as Deputy Attorney General Matt
Whittaker was Jeff Sessions chief of
staff he was a staffer he was never
confirmed at any level by the Senate and
every single legal opinion that I am
reading pat from the left and right that
actually understands this nuance is
saying Whittaker can't be there and this
is a constitutional problem
yeah and just by every just like that by
every standard the replacement at least
as Acting Attorney General right now
should be the deputy which is rod
Rosenstein but from Trump's perspective
Rosenstein is even worse than Jeff
Sessions Rosenstein is the guy who
started the Muller probe so there's no
sense in him firing Jeff Sessions or at
least forcing him out just to have some
guy who's worse bring up the rear and
and they're a probably able to get away
with this because it's going to be a
limited time period when Whittaker is
actually serving and it's going to get
us to a point where we're all just he
sensitized the whole thing and if
Whittaker does indeed and the Muller
probe there probably won't be that much
backlash I hope you're wrong but I worry
Pat that you are right and even John you
won
the most repulsive right-wing legal
scholars he's the guy who refused to
clearly answer whether or not the
president could order a terror suspect
buried alive remember that exchange with
John Conyers years ago even John you
says that the Whitaker appointment goes
too far in an email to Axios John you
wrote that quote the Constitution says
that principal officers must go through
appointment with the advice and consent
of the Senate
in Morrison V Olson the Supreme Court
made clear that the Attorney General is
a principal officer
therefore Whitaker cannot serve as
Acting Attorney General despite the
vacancies Act which does provide for him
to be acting AG the statute is
unconstitutional when applied in this
way this is no bleeding heart liver
liberal legal scholar and the next step
which we're going to talk about after
the break is that Trump now is starting
to distance himself from Matthew
Whitaker as the White House has been
taken aback by the reaction to the
Whitaker appointment it genuinely seems
that the White House had no idea that
this was going to explode into a
situation where legal scholars on the
left and right are of the mindset that
this is not okay and Trump now is
pretending he doesn't even know the guy
despite having met with him multiple
times we're gonna talk about that after
the break I want to hear your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show things are going to get crazy for
the next week that's for sure I am
thrilled to tell you that one of today's
sponsors is simple habit comm slash
Pakman where you can go and get a 7-day
totally free trial of an app that I use
personally and love I've talked to you
before about the benefits of meditation
just simply sitting there observing what
it is that your mind wants to do has
been a great thing for me we have so
much evidence growing all the time that
this is just a good thing for people to
do and one of the best tools you'll be
able to
anywhere online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the East and West you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work there are meditations
specially crafted to help people deal
with anxiety or to get focused before
doing something difficult and simple
habit lets you keep track of your
progress by giving you feedback about
how much you're meditating how many days
in a row you've been meditating it's a
really comprehensive and well put
together app go check it out you can try
it free for seven days at simple habit
calm / Pakman I've put a link underneath
this video